Major breaking news as Washington DC
runs runs runs away from the fact that
they got terribly spanked in that huge
case of Tyrie Benson versus the United
States and DC. Specifically, that huge
win for the Second Amendment that said
that magazines that hold more than 10
rounds are indeed protected arms under
the Second Amendment. Well, DC trying to
escape the results of that, but I'm
happy to report that the attorney for
Tyrie Benson has just responded and
blown up the arguments of the request by
the District of Columbia to shut down
the win for the Second Amendment. It's
not looking good for DC. It's looking
very good for the Second Amendment.
Let's break it all down when we come
right back.
>> [music]
>> Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of Diner, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar,
and proud to see the top voice of the
Second Amendment in America. Thank you.
2025 and 2026 Gundy's Awards. All right,
folks. So, we have major news here. As
you know, one of the most important
Second Amendment fights we're literally
fighting as we speak is to make sure
that that huge Second Amendment victory
that we experienced just a week or so
ago in the DC Court of Appeals that held
unequivocally in an excellent opinion
that magazines that hold more than 10
rounds are protected arms under the
Second Amendment. Because arms, as in
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms, shall not be infringed, includes
magazines. Why? Because the Supreme
Court in brewin in 2022 specifically
said that an arm for the purposes of the
text of the Second Amendment is any
instrument, any instrument that
facilitates armed self-defense.
Obviously, a magazine is an instrument.
It's a physical object and it obviously
facilitates armed self-defense in
several ways. Everything from helping
people train without hearing loss and
also being able to shoot effectively
without going deaf when you really
really need to hear your environ
environment around you if you're, you
know, touching off round in the middle
of the home and so on and so on. We know
the arguments. Big win in this case of
Tyrie Benson versus the United States
where Mr. Benson uh was convicted of
possessing a mal prohibitum crime. of
course, merely possessing a magazine
that held more than 10 rounds in
violation of the District of Columbia
law that prohibited that. And Janine
Perrell, Donald Trump, Pam Bonnie,
Department of Justice came in and
rescued the day by filing a major brief
in September 2025,
arguing indeed that magazines are
protected arms under the Second
Amendment and they cannot be banned and
nor can magazines at home more than 10
rounds be banned. And the DC Court of
Appeals, which is the highest court in
the District of Columbia, it's the
equivalent legally as a state supreme
court like the Supreme Court of Alabama,
the Supreme Court of Montana, the
Supreme Court of Florida, whatever. It's
the High Court of DC found indeed that
magazines hold more than 10 rounds are
magazines textually under the Second
Amendment. And there's no historical
tradition of regulating them or
restricting them or banning them I
should say because under the Supreme
Court decision of Heler the only kind of
arms that can be banned in American life
are those that are dangerous and unusual
and as you know if an arm is in common
use by Americans for lawful purposes by
definition it cannot be unusual and thus
by extension it cannot be dangerous and
unusual because it's not unusual.
Seabball hitball stuff. If you watch the
four box of diner, you know this and do
it even better than I am. I might put
myself out of a job for you guys to take
over the four box of diner. One day
because you won't need me anymore
because you'll be smarter than I am on
all these issues. That of course is the
goal. Okay, folks. So anyway, so what's
just happened here is the District of
Columbia Colombia uh in a panic really
uh raced to the DC Court of Hills and
said, "NO, STOP. STOP. YOU CAN'T LET
THIS BIG WIN for the Second Amendment go
into effect. is going to cause chaos.
It's causing a split of authority.
There's all sorts of insanity going
across uh DC and arguably across the
country. Please DC appeals do something
to stop this from going into effect,
which of course any other decision would
go into effect right away. No big deal.
But of course, because this involves
guns and the District Columbia hates
guns, they are freaking out. They are
clearly panicking in my opinion. So,
what has just happened is the attorneys
or the attorney for Ty Reed Benson has
just filed an opposition basically
attacking uh the District of Columbia's
position arguing that it's insane what
DC is arguing for here. This is not a
big deal. The DC court of appeals
applied the law of the second amendment
to this DC law. is clearly
unconstitutional and what DC is asking
for. This unprecedented, extraordinary
relief, is simply crazy talk and should
not be allowed to move forward. Here's
what Tyrie Benson's lawyer had to say,
arguing that the DC request to shut down
this big win for the Second Amendment
should not occur. Here's her argument.
This court should deny the District of
Columbia's emergency motion to suspend
the presidential status of the opinion
in this case pending disposition of the
district's forthcoming petition for
rehearing on bunk. This novel this novel
request finds no support in any statute,
rule, or judicial decision, and the
District of Columbia cites none. Not
only are the district's stated reason
for its request unfounded, but it does
not identify any extraordinary
circumstances that would justify such an
unprecedented departure from this
court's established rules of appellet
procedure. That's exactly right.
Basically, what uh Tyreek Benson's
lawyer is arguing against the DC
argument here against DC is to say,
"Look, you're literally just pulling
stuff out of your DUPA because you don't
like this decision. You lost. The Second
Amendment won. It's clearly the right
decision. The United States Department
of Justice under Pam Bonnie, Harmy
Dylan, Donald Trump, and of course,
Janine Piro, the US Attorney for the
District of Columbia, all are on the
right side here. And Tyreek Benson's
conviction for possessing a magazine
that held more than 10 rounds has to go
bye-bye. Stop making stuff up. stop uh
trying to invent theories that shut down
this big win for the Second Amendment
and the right to keep in arms is the
essence of the argument by the attorney
for Tyrie Benson. And here is how they
basically explain it in civil terms that
there ain't no there there, right?
There's no there there would justify uh
the District of Columbia Court of
Appeals basically shutting down the
presidential value of this major brick
in the wall defending our Second
Amendment rights. Check it out. Not only
does the District of Columbia fail to
site any legal authority to support its
novel request, but it fails to identify
anything extraordinary about the opinion
or the circumstances of this case that
would warrant creating an entirely new
remedy out of whole cloth without any
rules, procedures, or legal standards to
guide the decision and without any of
the public notice and comment that
ordinarily precedes a change in the
court's rules. Rather, the District of
Columbia merely repeats the same
complaints about the court's decision
that the division has already considered
and rejected.
At best, the District of Columbia stated
reasons for suspending the presidential
effect of the opinion are mere arguments
for rehearing the case on bon. Even if
these arguments are meritorious, which
as explained below, they are not, they
present no special reason to depart from
this court's established procedure for
reviewing division opinions that
conflict with the decision of the court
or decide questions of exceptional
importance. That's exactly right.
Remember how I've explained to you on
this channel, I want you in the Second
Amendment community to not only
understand substantive law. It's very
important, of course, to understand what
does the text of the Second Amendment
mean. It's very important to understand
the way to do the historical analysis to
determine if there's a historical
tradition of firearms regulation in the
United States to figure out whether or
not a modern day gun control law can
stand or fall under the Second
Amendment. And by the way, I want to
stop for a moment. I'm going to stop. I
want you to listen carefully to this
because I want to deal with something I
keep hearing on social media and I want
to address it real quick because it
speaks to this issue a little bit. Okay?
A lot of people out there say things
like the words in the second amendment
are shall not be infringed, the right of
the people to keep and bear shall not be
infringed and they think that just
saying shall not be infringed is the end
of the argument. And while we might want
that to be the case, here's the reality
on the ground.
We also say, and it's also correct to
say that the Second Amendment codified
a pre-existing right. So listen
carefully to this. The Second Amendment
cottified a pre-existing right. The
Second Amendment did not create rights.
It codified pre-existing rights. as a
consequence for modern-day courts to
determine whether or not a modern day
gun control law violates the Second
Amendment. Part of what the Supreme
Court has to do is analyze through
history
what exactly was the scope of the right
to keep and bear arms when the Second
Amendment was adopted. Because again, if
you think about it, if the Second
Amendment's text is about codifying a
pre-existing right, we as attorneys,
they as judges, if you will, have to
figure out what was the right
that was being codified in 1791 when the
Second Amendment was adopted. What is
included in the right and what is
excluded from the right? You see what
I'm saying? Because to have a right, you
have to know what's in the right, what
consists of the right, what's makes up
the right. And at the same time, to
define what something is, you also have
to be able to define what it is not. So
when you define what is a cat, you
describe what a cat is. And at the same
time, you have to describe what a cat is
not. So we recognize when we see a dog
walking down the street, we understand
why that is a dog and not a cat. So too
with the right to keep and bear arms, we
have to make sure we understand what
consists of the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed and what is excluded from
that. And we use history there because
again the second amendment codified the
historical right to keep and bear arms
which means we have to use history to
figure out the contours of the right. So
always keep that in mind. It's not
although I would like it to just be wave
the magic wy shall not be infringed. I'm
telling you, this is how it works in the
real world. And you don't turn into the
four boxes diner for me to blow smoke up
your dupa and tell you stories about
rains and unicorns. That's not the
purpose of this channel. I talk to you
in the real world uh with what we're
really confronting and with real people,
with real judges, with real lawyers, for
better or for worse. And that is
something you got to understand. Okay.
So, with that brief digression, I just
want to circle back here to talk about
how uh this uh this argument by the
lawyer for Tyrie Benson really points
out how absurd it is that DC is trying
to shut this down. And it's important to
understand that Mr. Benson's attorney is
really laying out it's absurd for DC to
argue that there's chaos on the streets
when that's simply not true. Here's what
they have to say. rebutting DC's
argument says, "If you don't stop this
opinion from taking effect, there'll be
chaos in DC and beyond." Check it out.
In asking this court to suspend the
presidential effect of its opinion, the
District of Columbia claims that the
opinion is creating real chaos on the
ground because a criminal with an
unregistered firearm might be able to
insulate himself from liability simply
by attaching an 11 plus round magazine
to it. Not only does the district site
no evidence of any real chaos on the
ground, but the potential chaos
hypothesized by the district can easily
and entirely be avoided by the listen
carefully folks by the district's
immediate goodfaith compliance with the
court's decision in this case rather
than a fancyfold request to suspend the
legal effect of the opinion. Wow, that's
very funny. They really slammed DC's
argument to say, "I'm sorry you don't
like guns. I'm sorry you don't like the
fact that you got your butt kicked by
the DC Court of Appeals, but you know,
suck it up, buttercup, and move on. If
you're worried about chaos, have the
attorney general, if you will, that runs
the legal department for the District of
Columbia come out and issue an opinion
to say, "Hey, you know what? Our law is
unconstitutional. We're not going to
enforce it anymore." And by the way,
Janine Piro is the US attorney for the
District of Columbia already said
they're not enforcing this law that
prohibits individuals from having
magazines that hold more than 10 rounds
in DC. They have not been enforcing this
since at least September. Big win for
the Second Amendment thanks to the Bondi
Janine Perroll Donald Trump
administration. something good on the
second amendment that done for us in a
really big way because this decision
that the Bondi Trump administration with
Janine Piro at the helm here uh helped
gave give rise to is a split of
authority and that split of authority as
we've talked about on this channel over
the last few days has given rise to
several legal briem to none other than
the United States Supreme Court included
in the cases of Gator Custom Guns and
Duncan versus Bont explained to the
Supreme Court now we have a split of
author authority as to whether or not
magazines are protected arms in the
Second Amendment. And it's time for the
Supreme Court to step up and resolve the
split of authority right here and right
now. And I could not agree more. Now,
with that said, this is how the lawyer
for Tyrie Benson summarizes uh and and
finishes off her legal brief saying to
DC, "Go pound sand." Check it out. In
sum, all of District of Columbia's
stated reasons for suspending the
opinion's presidential effect, while
this court considers a forthcoming
petition for rehearing onbunk boil down
to arguments that the case was wrongly
decided and merits an onbank review. But
under this court's established rules of
appellet procedure, even a wronglydeed
opinion retains presidential force
unless and until it is vacated following
the grant of a petition for reharbanc.
The District of Columbia offers no
special reason for this court to depart
from its ordinary order of operations
and to first strip the opinion of its
binding effect before the court has had
the opportunity to consider whether to
grant reharing on bond. Nor does it site
any case, statute, or rule that would
support its request. The District of
Columbia's motion should be denied.
Exactly right. Very compelling
arguments. Again, the history of the
future is yet to be written, so we'll
see what happens here. But there's no
doubt this is a fantastic win for the
Second Amendment and very bad news for
the anti-gunners all across America,
including the anti-gunners that are in
the deep state in Washington DC. a big
win for Tyrie Benson uh and the United
States Department of Justice in this
particular case because again it was
Donald Trump, Pam Bonnie and Janine Piro
that gave rise to this big win for their
huge support of Tyreek Benson and
arguing that this magazine ban of DCs
did indeed violate the Second Amendment.
We covered this in a big way in
September and I said this is major
breaking news. A lot of people said it's
not a big deal Mark. Why you bother me
with major breaking news? And the answer
is now you see why. So, when I call
things major breaking news, even if it's
not obvious to certain people as to why
that's the case, you should probably
take me at my word because, as you can
see here, uh I can often see down the
chessboard of something that looks like
a really big deal that may not be
obvious to others. And then we find out
6 months later, it gives rise to a split
of authority that may ultimately allow
the Supreme Court to step up and
vindicate our right to keep embarrassed
to semi-automatic rifle bans like the
AR-15. And yes indeed to magazine bans
for magazines that hold more than 10
rounds. Those are big big wins and I
suspect there's an excellent chance
we're going to get them very soon from
the Supreme Court. Perhaps as early as
next term. Fingers crossed, candles lit.
Let's hope for the best. All right,
folks. There you have it. I hope you
enjoyed today's episode. Make sure you
follow me over there on X4boxes Diner.
Don't forget to subscribe both the
YouTube and the Rumble. And I look
forward to talking to all of you again
very very soon here at the Four Boxes
Diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2 A.